mais mais mais ce n'est pas modern
warfare 2 au nom de dieu j entre l'oms
et squeeze on se retrouve aujourd'hui
pour vous une petite vidéo la toute
première ever sur ma chaîne youtube
enfin driver de youtube un éleveur de
bisous à moi fins ma première vidéo que
je fais sur w3 bref cas quiproquos en
tout début de vidéo c'est incroyable
alors donc bah écoute et dans quel but
fait cette vidéo et bien tout simplement
pour vous dire mes impressions et ce que
je pense du jeu donc c'est un petit
gameplay au elles sont 18 h quai valin
dossena coeur qu'on a dès le début donc
avec le bar est et on se retrouve sur la
mappe lockdown en domination donc
l'acédémie la partie vous avez pas vu le
compteur du début du tout début parce
que genco assez foireuse et ça me fait
rejoindre la partie un petit peu après
enfin moi donc alors se modérera
farthouat n'a écouté que dire un bon ça
se voit sûrement pas sûr sur la vidéo
mais je trouve que les textures ont déjà
été quand même amélioré ses textures un
peu plus belle je trouve qu'elles sont
pas enfin comment dire les couleurs sont
pas aussi fade que dans mozart à part de
iai c'est quand même plus colorés je
sais pas s'il vous pouvez bois holà aux
mondieux quelques elle m'a sali bat rain
roseraie on est là pour parler de jouer
pas pour déconner cette fois ci les gens
alors donc je disais donc les textures
chocolat ont été améliorés les couleurs
ont aussi été améliorés je veux dire que
ça donne en plus de charme au jeu tout
simplement donc ça ça devait être quoi
ma septième partie ol 4 ol 118 à part
dont gilles ressemble tellement l 96 que
j'ai envie de dire à 96 donc voilà au
plomb graphismes c'est quand même un peu
mieux bon ya pas de grands progrès
c'est pas comme le passage de bfbc2 à
bf3 mais quand même c'est déjà pas mal
je peux vous dire que on l'a attendu ce
fucking god of war iii et franchement il
vaut le coup je trouve vraiment bien un
petit remarquer en passant il y en a
toujours eu et je te dire que est
franchement ça valait le coup de le
prendre alors au niveau des armes ya de
nombreuses un média pas des nouvelles
armes et il faut savoir que les armes
qui ne sont pas nouvelles sont un
nouveau skin est parfois un nouveau
bruit mais pas tout le temps mon façon
ça tout le monde un jeu donc je pense
que vous savez bien enfin bref je trouve
ça je trouve ça c'est sympa quand même
d'avoir des nouveaux skins au niveau des
armes qu'on connaît déjà
bon par exemple l'espace 12 ya pas une
grande évolution mais quand même ça peut
être plaisant qu'on joue avec même s'ils
allaient les aléas dans les codeurs
d'activision se trouvait pas de mots ont
tellement eu de retour mauvais sur ce
paquebot ce genre ouais c'est tchité la
nature millionaire fait mais un point
inimaginable maintenant vous pouvez
faire d'être marqueur à un mètre du mec
comme vous pouvez le suivre un maître
cesser complètement random j'ai
l'impression enfin c'est assez bizarre
pas mon truc
enfin je me suis pas penché sur le sujet
alors au niveau des série d'éliminations
parsemant franchement j'ai trouvé que
c'était quand même c'est vachement
original ce qu'ils ont fait je sais pas
si vous êtes d'accord
ils ont fait donc le truc assauts donc
c'est à dire des killstreaks plutôt
orienté pour tuer les ennemis
notamment predator et tout ça et
franchement c'est vraiment pas mal donc
on part quand il faut pas mourir sinon
ça a vu de la série ils ont fait quelque
chose de soutien c'est à dire pour
appuyer ses coéquipiers donc c'est plus
des killstreaks offensé sur par exemple
je prends l'exemple par exemple du
mastodonte qui est dispo dans l'est dans
les deux types de faim dans un assaut et
soutien dans les deux types de
killstreak on va dire eh ben le
mastodonte du un saut il a une armée
bourrine et le masters golf du soutien
il a pas l'anglais un bouclier et il
doit justement cover ses alliés prendre
les points par exemple aux dominations
j'ai trouvé ça franchement intéressant
franchement j'ai bien aimé ça puis après
j'ai introduit un nouveau truc bon ça
j'accroche pas trop hein gagner à un
atout tous les deux de kif je crois que
c'est ça bon je trouve ça cern
tu peux a rien dans sa séquence veut
faire tomber ce faire un petit chiffre
est bon sans plus puis on a ajouté des
petits qui le strip aussi ça va c'est
c'est plutôt pas mal mais enfin bon on
l'a fini pour les districts farm
ils ont ajouté du nouveau ils ont ils
ont mis à le truc en soutien ou quand
vous mourrez ça n'annule pas la série ça
c'est quand même sacrément bien et puis
voilà au niveau des snipers ont mis le
paquet c'est à dire qu'il est dispo pour
rentrer presque tous temps donc là je
joue sur pc pas la manette
je souris clavier je veux dire que les
cuisses qu ils rendent franchement mais
très très mais vraiment très bien mon
classe le voyait à l'écran c'est le seul
qui le strict offensif enfin
bombardement de la place en fin de ce
district il soutient donc c'est un truc
qui fait presque toute la map que vous
obtenez au bout de 14 et mination je
crois donc vous pouvez mourir entre
temps à présent pour la mujer cinq fois
tué deux mecs mon rêve cette fois tu es
des mecs
quatorze femmes auraient tués deux mais
enfin ça serait ballot comme partira
et puis et puis voilà donc c'est
vraiment enfin que dire je partais plus
tôt je partais franchement sur un point
négatif du pas vous mentir je me disais
ouais ben voilà il nous fut se foutent
de notre gueule ces mêmes graphismes ils
ont fait les mêmes choses
mw2 les lots du foutage de gueule et ça
sincèrement c'est le raisonnement
typique de ceux qui n'ont jamais joué
avant d'y avoir joué à la paris games
week je disais ça et sincèrement je suis
pas ça vraiment un très gros charme de
d'obtenir de nouveaux sons d'armes de
nouvelles armes des nouveaux trucs même
si en soi c'est vrai que c'est pas
complètement nouveau jeu ça on va pas se
le cacher c'est pas vraiment un nouveau
jeu une révolution ou quoi mais c'est
plutôt plaisant à voir avec l'âge je
tiens le mastodonte je dois faire du jeu
c'est pas 18 10 à peu près là 18 qui dit
mort je suis sûr regardez ce sniper il
est vraiment mais excellence j'ai
vraiment adoré c'est vraiment un sniper
vent très bon et au niveau des marqueurs
on en fait moins de douane w de ça par
contre c'est quelque chose je suis
persuadé qu en fait moi ne me brisez pas
qu'on en fait pas moins parce que c'est
complètement faux je suis sûr et certain
qu'on a tellement sur un doublé v2 on en
fait vraiment très souvent alors que là
vous voyez c'est bon à sauf si on retire
dans le biais d'accords gabon mais
franchement je trouve qu'on en fait moi
et avec n'importe quel sniper alors donc
tu as on obtient donc ce qu'est street
mastodonte vous voyez j'ai le rush pour
le pt au bouclier
malheureusement on le vole donc
multiplier il est déjà dans un état
pitoyable je vois que rien quand
j'arrête de courir voilà c'est génial on
a une super lui redire un peu des merdes
des pigeons qui sont sur le bouclier fin
bref c'est ça c'est sale et plus bas l'a
personnellement c'est la première fois
que j'avais le district donc mes
premières impressions c'est une [ __ ]
mais combien pèse cette foutue
combinaison 400 kg ou quoi ce bordel et
en fait non elle doit peser dans les 672
n'en soit rien elle est vraiment super
long cours comme un gros porc donc je
pense que l'âge est en mode web de
gentioux de l'idole en fait j'aurais pas
dû j'aurais plutôt pensé à aider mes
coéquipiers à prendre les points bon
j'étais tellement heureux de tester
niveau district j'étais nerveux trop
bien ouais voilà au final j'ai quand
même réussi à prendre
- evo littéralement mitraillées vous
allez voir ça va pas être efficace et
elsa et voir comment je vais mourir un
espèce de gros mots un kamikaze a tué
palomino
et ben voilà prends toi ça dont georges
kamikazes il était au top
enfin bon je donne ces se nourrit du
strict il est assez plaisant bon c'est
plus pour se marrer qu'autre chose
ces histoires de droits linguistiques
mastodonte trop il vous êtes super
résistant et vous pouvez d'équité devant
moi se trouve ça sert plus à savon après
c'est ça que c'est clair que c'est un
peu marrant mais bon voilà pas de grosse
révolution du nil et gastriques non plus
au niveau des maps au niveau des maps
que dire sincèrement c'est de la merde
non sans rire j'ai bien aimé bah tout
les mêmes que j'ai testée jusqu'à
présent donc c'est à dire enfin
donald que j'aime particulièrement pas
et y en a pleins gens qu'il aime et je
là je n'aime pas je n'aime pas il y en a
une c'est un jeu s'est passé en afrique
de france je sais pas trop le genre de
personnages sont des bois rappelle je
suis pas raciste ou quoi c'est tout il
s'entendait le mot noir à la city c'est
le noir opaque baltard non pas du tout
c'est juste que voilà il y à icc un pays
un peu house climat est très chaud afin
que l'histoire géo en direct de la vidéo
alors là donc le climat est très chaud
c'est plutôt un climat pencher mais
durera bien me souvenir le troisième en
soirée mais voilà donc c'est un espèce
de espèce de villages d'afrique et enfin
je n'ai pas trop aimé c'est pas parce
que vous avez dans ce jeu pas assez
c'est un soir ça que je n'ai pas aimé ne
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dis franchement c'est juste que je sais
pas acheter ou qu'elle est toute en
longueur il ya plein de petits passagers
au milieu de la map fin franchement je
n'ai pas trop aimé une autre pape au
milieu d'un gros trou dans le sol je
sais plus le nom ça doit être je sais
plus dans spy de la boire c'est une
autre gloire en sachant que c'est une
autre il ya trop mieux de la map avec le
conduit en dessous mais celle ci je n'ai
pas vraiment aimé parce qu'il ya trop de
chemin mais sinon personnellement toutes
les étapes je les aime ce qui fait que
demain tu que je n'aime pas c'est quand
même assez fort jusqu'à massés au
franc-parler a par exemple sur un doublé
de karachi que je vais pas en vase ion
ça va j'ai bien fait mais on va pas
reparler de ce jeu c'est bon elle est
aux oubliettes gelé mis dans la poubelle
j'ai mis du scotch sur les deux sur la
poubelle et j'avais mal franchement
[ __ ] il me gave mw2 vo la la fois les
plans mais qui retournera sur un w 2
après avoir joué le w3 par minimum un
mois après je veux bien comprendre mais
pendant un mois
vous allez seigner mw3 ya pas moyen sauf
ceux qui ont besoin sauf ceux qui ont
des obligations ils doivent faire le
noir ou je sais pas quoi
enfin moala grosso modo ce jeu
personnellement je il m'a bien il m'a
bien plu je veux dire qu'il ya pas grand
chose qui met dessus ne serait-ce que
les graphismes sont quand même restés
relativement comme avant ça c'est clair
et net
ils ont vraiment mis le paquet pour
améliorer le gameplay on dirait qu'ils
ont écouté les joueurs au niveau des
marqueurs au niveau de tout ça seule
déception ne peut pas doubler switch et
cherré juste après comme on faisait avec
l'intervention ce que je trouve très
content et j'ai l'impression que les
mains qui ont été faites pour faire des
kits fils alors celle retenue parce que
je vais vous dire il ya quand même plein
demain vont passer s'il ya plein de là
où en domination il ya des spots mais
nous on trime pour faire d'utile fluide
et ça franchement jeu j'en ai déjà
repéré trois quatre cinq et je peux me
dire que je m'en souviendrai très bien
très très bien et peut-être que je sois
des vidéos pour montrer les spectres je
trouve d'ailleurs j'en sais rien enfin
vous voilà sur modern warfare 3
personnellement je partais en disant
ouais ça va être deux points sont sous
l'eau est en fait l'on écoute et je
pense que ceux qui l'ont testé peuvent
penser ça c'est clair mais ils ont quand
même bien amélioré gameplay écouter les
joueurs et ça je veux dire ça fait
vraiment franchement plaisir en tout cas
j'espère cette vidéo vous aura plu je
vous invite tout de suite je remets le
menu à regarder le mode survival avec la
flight parlons [ __ ] j'ai à chaque fois
je confonds avec fally ou je sais pas
quoi
avec fly ou alors vous pouvez tout
simplement appliqué voir la domination
avec beaucoup de monde de l'asie chao
tout le monde bail
m